here's where we begin president Trump
and his supporters say Democrats they've
gone too far with claims of wrongdoing
after Robert Muller found the president
did not collude with Russia some
Republicans are now talking about
revenge House Democrats say their
investigations will continue six
committee chairmen wrote to Attorney
General William Barr demanding the
release of the special counsels report
no later than April 2nd Senate
Republican leaders blocked a resolution
yesterday calling for Muller's full
findings to be made public major Garrett
is at the White House major good morning
good morning you might remember
President Trump called a Muller
investigation of witch-hunt hoax accused
muller of supervising a pack of angry
democratic thugs well yesterday he said
in fact Muller active quote honorably
and the investigation was carried out
just fine think of that as the turn of
the 20/20 campaign where a rally site
you're gonna hear talk of vindication
exoneration and already predictions here
at the White House the Democrats are
gonna have to live with this president
for six more years I think the Democrats
have way overstepped and overplayed this
Republicans are convinced even without
the benefit of the full mullah report
President Trump in his campaign did not
collude with Russians or obstruct
justice and they are accusing Democrats
of grotesque overreach what they did and
it was a false narrative who was it was
a terrible thing very few people I know
could have handled it president Trump's
2020 campaign now fundraising off the
probes conclusion and going so far as to
send this memo to TV producers listening
discredited guests all Democrats who
pushed quote outlandish false collusion
accusations it's really the Democrats
with their media lackeys creating a
narrative that they want to be true
because they couldn't explain the
outcome of the last election seemingly
free of Mullah related jeopardy the
president was at ease yesterday meeting
with the Stanley Cup champion Washington
Capitals and sharing a joke with Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
himself a target of a corruption probe
I've got you okay
[Music]
the president also previewed not only a
20/20 campaign theme but threads of a
new investigation into how the Muller
probe was launched there are a lot of
people out there that have done some
very very evil things very bad things I
would say treasonous things against our
country those people will certainly be
looked at Democrats searching for a post
and Muller foothold are settling on
demanding the full Mullen report and its
underlying evidence whatever you feel
there is no good reason not to make the
report public this letter to attorney
General William Barr from six Democratic
committee chairs calls bars for paid
summary of the Muller report not
sufficient for Congress as it conducts
its own investigation into the president
mr. Barr is an appointee of the
president so I have a lot of questions
both about the conclusions and the
process that was followed the Attorney
General has advisors are working now on
not just to find out how much of the
report can be made public there are
justice department rules that in general
suggest against releasing information
related ongoing investigations grand
jury testimony classified information
but as congressional Democrats have
pointed out in Viana
in times of high public interest and in
pursuit of transparency those rules have
been waived and not to be in this case
as well that's right and Barr did say
that he would release as much as
possible before this report came major
thank you